and by the power of castle hate skull i
h-a-r-l-e-y just in case you're spelling
impaired
just in case you have dysgraphia which i
learned this weekend uh
when somebody came back at me after i
called them out for misspelling the word
losing they said well i have dysgraphia
but they were talking smack to me
already so i was like yeah you can't do
that though you can't be like
f you mark harley and then i'm like you
spelled
fu wrong like i can't spell and it's a
disability did they spell it loosing
they did i i'm guilty of that saying
right well you're also not talking smack
to me on the internet you don't know
that they're right i could have a
speaker to counter that fuel in oh my
god it was coming from inside the
building the entire time yeah it was an
inside job fake boys studios undermining
their star
uh star podcaster this is what people
will use to go out of context and be
like see mark's a narcissist by the way
i challenged everyone in the subreddit
to define the mental illness that i
suffer from
and one person posted a list of
narcissistic traits on my uh
on the last podcast episode
without any evidence of how i you know
how my behavior applies to those traits
and so i just replied with a list of
traits of pedophilia and said the
responding
the person has commented uh is a
pedophile as you can see here's a list
of those traits
same thing right logic is difficult
we'll get to that in a second though
we'll get to all sorts of things
relating to
the drama in my life uh once we get over
some trauma in some other people's lives
sounds like a real loser it sounds like
this guy's an obvious loser
i've never seen such a loser
he's a real loose cannon
um we're doing a new segment today it's
called overheard on the amber heard
trial oh wow that's news to me i mean
[Laughter]
sorry casey i sprung this on you casey's
like
but normally i prep for hours on these
segments
um
so you know
i have been fascinated with this in part
because of the psychological elements of
it right to me it's more than just drama
between two people and he said she said
because at first when it was that it's
it's like who cares right two people in
a relationship making claims about one
another but when it gets to the point
where
you're having experts testify with
contradictory testimony about somebody's
psychological impairment i mean i relate
to that too because again a lot of these
dudes are literally claiming i have
mental illness it's like
then give the evidence testify to what
my mental illness is and you can't or
you know i get to rebut or whatever or
if i do rebut anybody they say
see it's a symptom of mental illness
that you're responding to me right
so i guess uh the fact that this expert
is giving her testimony in response to
somebody else critiquing her testimony
is evidence of her mental illness
according to that logic but
the video in question
is johnny depp expert rips amber heard
psychologist for misrepresenting
testimony if you wanted to look that up
um
and we you know we you don't have to
play it but it's
like this is it it's these are a series
of videos that don't have commentary on
them so every day i've been you know
they are
the headlines are a little clickbaity
but actually pretty accurate you know
like they're enticing it you'll know
what's in the video like yesterday was
one
that talked about the fact that
some of these videos that were leaked to
tmz came directly from amber heard and
how do you know that
even if
you know you're just the video editor
because of the copyright situation right
if like if you get a video from somebody
else they have to clear the copyright to
it which can take
days they really do it through a check
on it so the fact that they were
immediately able to post it it's like
this came from the copyright owner who's
the copyright i ever heard and you know
there's actually a much longer video
where you can see her like snickering
into the camera afterwards and i forget
what the specific thing was but she's
obviously like you know this was like a
bombshell that came out
still interesting not as interesting as
this which was
something that i try to convey to people
when
the
dep team psychological expert or you
know expert testimony
giver
was
basically testifying that amber heard
suffers from borderline personality and
not ptsd even those two things have
overlapping symptoms and
you know might look superficially
similar in some ways but have very
different sources and different uh
implications
for
somebody who's claiming to be the victim
of abuse in a
trial right
she testified
that you know essentially
she administered these tests that are
designed to catch people lying and not
specifically but it's like you know look
the simplest test for any personality
disorder would just be do you have this
disorder if somebody could have complete
access to their own
mind objectively and have also expertise
to be able to diagnose you know you
could just ask somebody
are you a narcissist are you a
psychopath do you have borderline
personality disorder are you
schizophrenic you know do you suffer
from bipolar simple
however
there must be other indicators
especially if there's consequences to
that where you're trying to appear one
way or you're incentivized to appear one
way or the other so
she
you know goes through how the
amber heard psychologists
inappropriately use certain tests and
i'm just gonna give you some examples um
she
gave her a uh ptsd checklist which
uh is a screening instrument only right
and she was using it as a tester like to
see do you have ptsd
you're also supposed to give this at a
certain time and place right all these
things have relevance and
the situation and time in which you give
them is very important so giving us you
know somebody a screening a ptsd
checklist it's a screening instrument
only
where it lists every single symptom
potential symptom of ptsd
because this is the most frequently
claimed and feigned
diagnosis in civil court
you're essentially handing somebody a
checklist of ptsd
symptoms and you're teaching them all
the little nuances that that the
psychologist would be looking for to
actually diagnose ptsd so it's like do
you suffer from any of these if there's
no mechanism to throw you off from that
and somebody wanted to manipulate or
exploit
that information to seem like they have
ptsd when they don't
you gave him a cheat sheet right
and she basically checked off everyone
there's a danger assessment scale oh and
by the way like if you you know
it's like essentially impossible to have
more than a certain number if you list
like 13 symptoms of ptsd like
there's just you know perhaps never been
a case where everybody has all 13 right
are you aware i didn't know anything
about it but like oh right that makes
sense because you know you'll have ptsd
is probably a pretty broad umbrella
and also
um you know you have different things
that would cause that ptsd via different
you know
senses even
so
uh
you know and then another thing that i
think is relevant to that real quick is
it impairs your function right so if you
have ptsd you're not normally able to
work and one of the big things was like
amber heard continue to go on and do
things like become a you know sommelier
in training and do acting movies like
but most people who have actual ptsd
find
a severe impairment of function where
you can't go to work you don't leave
your house like something changes
drastically behaviorally and that just
didn't seem to be
present as one of the primary things
that you'd look at so
the second thing she gave was a danger
assessment scale right and this is
talking about the woman working for
amber hurt and why she can be
discredited it's designed for nurses in
an emergency room
that's the setting right it's not a
retrospective measure to look back in
time and say
you know what happened three four five
six years ago
in this situation that we're now totally
removed from when you're in litigation
and incentivized to make yourself appear
as if
you're a battered wife um
the reason they give this apparently in
the emergency room it's like a list of
things where it's like how many times
has this happened in the last year how
many times has that happened you know
how many times your husband hit you
does your husband own a gun
you know has he ever threatened you with
a knife they list all these things
not to figure out if you're abused
because it's really for women who are
like in there with an injury and it's
super obvious that their husband beat
the crap out of them
and the injuries severe and it's
obviously an ongoing thing and they give
the woman a list to be like
maybe you'll wake up from from reading
all these things because
you're going to be in denial to some
degree you know or if you are in denial
they could give you this
and
try to induce some sort of light bulb
moment where you go
oh right maybe i am really in danger and
then you're more likely to seek
resources so
it's not something you give like six
years later to be like think back like
you know how many times did he hit you a
week did he have it was he dangerous
when you know there's millions of
dollars on the line for you to say that
he's dangerous and abusive
the other one she gave was the conflict
tactic scale
designed for research purposes uh to
research family violence anonymously so
you'd be filling this out like
anonymously so you have less incentive
to like you know essentially no
incentive to manipulate or exaggerate
whatever
and there's no controls for exaggeration
or minimization it's given to
participants anonymously to collect data
on the prevalence of abuse and how
abusive dynamics work broadly speaking
right so we're giving these patterns so
the other psychologists basically use
that to like self-report these things
you know each one of which was like out
of context and there was actually more
those are just four of them but um
including a mood disorder questionnaire
about symptoms bipolar
so
um
she basically you know she goes through
and breaks oh it's i mean it's insane to
me this woman like inappropriately
administered like several tests uh in
order to make this claim about amber
heard psychological state or having ptsd
versus depp's attorney claiming that she
had borderline and histrionic
personality i found that
damn interesting
and also the other thing was you know
that i'll say in contrast to that when
you give somebody what's called the
miller forensic assessment symptom test
again not claiming to be an expert i'm
just regurgitating what she says and
these are the
things that i found interesting in her
testimony and much more this is just
like a you know a few minutes of this
she talks about
um the miller forensic assessment
symptom test is a brief set of questions
you asked the examinee it's extremely
effective at revealing an examinee's
attempt to fake a severe mental illness
or psychosis
and psychosis is when somebody loses
touch with reality completely
that's the important part and broadly
speaking i'll wrap this up just by
saying
all the tests that had some sort of
instrument for measuring attempts to
exaggerate
their symptoms or minimize their
responsibility
she fell for right and in each scenario
that was consistent with people who have
personality disorders um because for
example
if you
if the participant is able to like suss
out what the questionnaire is looking
for you know because each questionnaire
they're not necessarily going to say
that they have these you know names that
don't necessarily indicate like you know
this is the crazy test right
the
participants if they have a mental
illness or or you know certain kinds of
of personality disorders are going to be
more likely to like
exaggerate you know their sort of like
victimhood minimize their responsibility
you know like like they're playing to
something and that catches you in things
because you know and even with the ptsd
test it's like
they'll throw in things that like aren't
symptoms of ptsd and you're claiming it
and it's like well gotcha because you're
so she scored in this like elite level
like one percent of people who like you
know are the biggest liars on these
tests essentially
and
um
it's
just
very interesting to note
that
the only person sort of defending her
and saying this it's like well you know
your objective data collection is
undermined right it's essentially to the
point of being worthless because if you
remove a test from its
designated context it's it's meaningless
or you implement one part of it wrong
it's meaningless and if you start
contradicting yourself the other answers
become meaningless right it adds weight
to like undermine the rest of your
answers even if those answers on their
own seem legitimate if the other half of
the question
questions are designed to sort of
measure your dishonesty on the first
half then you're screwed
makes sense i know that might be really
boring to some people but it's
interesting to me and probably the most
interesting part of this because you go
if that is the case if we can conclude
that she has certain traits
those things correlate
with lying with manipulation with
exploitation and a willingness to do
something as severe as lie about having
been the victim of violence in order to
get financial gain right
so that's to me that's always the
underlying thing it's not about like oh
did did this really happen or not in
this particular moment you have to look
at the character of the people
as objectively as possible and these
tests has really caught my interest in
as far as something that can actually
catch people who have
bad faith motives
in the act of lying exaggerating
minimizing and when they don't know
what's going on they do this thing where
it's like
they like over really overcompensate if
they can't tell what's going on in the
test
like they get super defensive and make
sure to like not have any expression of
ever having been responsible for
anything and then when it's asking them
a positive thing it's like they go way
over the top to make themselves seem
super angelic and everything i do is
positive and helpful and benevolent so
really interesting stuff i read you to
watch that
and if you're not into psychology like
me i urge you to never watch this
podcast again
all right
if you're watching this podcast you know
one thing is correct
i'm on kratom and not just any kratom
happy hippo kratom the best g dang
kratom in the entire universe from
happyhipporples.com
i do use it i do love it i do use it
responsibly
and i offer it up to you as something
that maybe you'll enjoy because it's
natural and it comes from plants dog so
if you've ever thought about trying
kratom
and want to see why i like it so much
and want to say hmm what's my favorite
method of ingesting kratom whether it's
powder whether it's the pills whether
it's the little
kratom energy shots
that tastes like five hour five hour
energy or whatever it's called six hour
seven hour four hours
you should give it a try go to
happyhippo herbals.com
use promo code thick boy with three c's
for 20 off not just that purchase
or
your next purchase but every purchase
for the rest of your life and if you're
listening to this
and they revoke those privileges at any
point you come to me
and all that happy hip herbals know uh
uh this ain't happening okay it's either
me or this anonymous fan here who
requested that i don't say their name
because they just really like kratom and
they want the discount okay wow mark
that's a really nice shirt you have on
it seems kind of tailored for a guy with
your build who has muscles who works out
who wants to look classy whether he's
podcasting or going to the improv to see
a cool show well tell you what it's
oakenstoneclothing.com
their stuff is nice it's high quality it
will
tell women that you approach
i know how to dress but i'm not
overdoing it all right
simple basic items like this high
quality fabrics ethically sourced
material
i urge you to give it a shot just go
just go to the website okay just check
it out
use promo code hella for that 10 off if
you do buy anything but there's no
obligation to buy you just visit the
site and picture yourself in these
clothes and then dm'ing me to tell me
that you got the clothes and then we're
trading pics and all of a sudden it's a
fashion show in the dms
and [ __ ] gets weird
can we move on casey are you done
hearing about the amber heard trial what
is your take on it no i wanted to go
into yeah there's like a 40 minute rant
that i would love to do now if given the
opportunity no i'm just kidding
we got time we got time cut mine out and
put yours in it'll probably be more
interesting um
you know but i do i was going to relate
it back to
you know
what's fun i've been telling people
lately like
certain guys from reddit will come
message me
and it's immediately apparent what their
motivations are and
it is kind of a gut instinct but part of
it i can sort of identify and put into
words which is
it's a sense of entitlement right these
guys come
and
instead of for example giving me a
sincere compliment that seems sincere
because they're giving me something
specific and almost making themselves
vulnerable because especially if you're
a guy to compliment other guy like
there's this like hashtag no homo like a
mentality of like i can't give a guy a
compliment almost on anything that seems
sincere and heartfelt without feeling
self-conscious about
my sexuality right that's just the
notion that
you don't i mean i tell you every
morning you have beautiful lips
i i don't think yeah i don't think you
suffer from that but like okay okay like
so i can continue to do so right yes
definitely continue to do so and anybody
complimenting me don't ever feel
self-conscious no i would i really do
you know it's just a weird thing it's
like why can't i get i don't know but
like i know it's a it's a cultural meme
and i know why we all do that because
everybody you know especially if you're
in like football or certain sports like
the whole matrix was like everybody
bullies kind of each other on the team
by saying no you're gay you're gay
you're gay you're gay you're gay you
know
and uh and then sometimes you know there
are gay football players on the team and
it's like that is hurtful and serious
and changes your perspective on things
um
but you know hopefully everybody has
that moment where you're like oh like
joking around like that with a teammate
is one thing doing it to you know or if
somebody even overhears that who is gay
like that's hurtful and and you
shouldn't do that
um but not everybody learns that
and
it's still internalized so what i'm
saying is when people dm me and give me
compliment you know there's just there's
like this little radar that goes off
where it's like this person is trying to
get something out of me or is like
rude in some way because real fans again
they'll usually lead with a longer
message like say what they
want to say express support in a way
that just feels more genuine and sincere
what is that it doesn't feel like
they're trying to get something or
a lot of times they'll just be like hey
and expect me to respond and then if i
do it's like they're starting to ask me
questions and give them information
about things which
you know a couple times of
i immediately recognize that you know
and then put things that i want them to
post
and and it gets posted and they think
they've gotten one over on me but the
fact of the matter is i knew from the
beginning because it's so obvious when
you're pushy or you're rude or you're
giving these little signs that you want
to come off as
something that you think i want which is
like a sycophantic person like telling
me how great and cool and handsome i am
it's like oh you're like first of all i
could tell when it's sincere or not but
like secondly you think you're like
greasing me up by doing that or
something like oh i'll just tell you
anything because you told me i'm good at
podcasting and handsome
not how it works gotta tell me i have a
big dick too so
given that it's almost like you know
making this comparison
to
those nuances and how you can sort of
trick and trap people you know to like
revealing their like i i really hey
casey i'm a huge fan i really like you
tell me everything about thick boy
studios that's the secret you know
it's like whoa that was weird and quick
and abrupt but you're too
immature
would be one way to put i don't even
mean that pejoratively it's just like
it's usually these guys are like
you know in this like teenage to 25
range that i'm like oh you lack the
social skills to even come off as
having gratitude or being honored to
have an exchange with somebody who if
you looked up to me you would feel a
certain way right um so even the fact
that you're remotely even treating me
like
neutral or condescending
betrays the fact that you're setting me
up in the first place like you really
like me you know or you really look up
to me or something like that
so it's just an interesting little thing
and
i do want to announce one of the most
important things that ever happened to
me which was getting es sneakers to
follow me on instagram
what and let's just look at that here
let's look at let's look you know a lot
of people said
i don't have any es sneakers oh really
no nobody said that um but i do have
like you know during the pandemic i went
nuts buying es sneakers about like
probably 15 pairs you know
and one of those things were like yeah
i'll just buy like 15 20 pairs and and
send some back that i don't like i sent
zero pairs of shoes back unless they
were like just a size that didn't fit me
um
and i just went and bought the same ones
off ebay
in the actual size i needed but i wanted
a suplex sneakers
i
talked about how i didn't know any of
the nike or jordans it doesn't make any
sense to me shout out to suplex i love
the sneakers you guys hooked me up with
and apparently people want them because
i posted them like oh who just came out
and i'll give you this much money for it
i'm like no because whatever you're
offering me obviously isn't the market
value price for that so i'm not gonna do
it
but i went and i was like man i don't
know anything about this because all i
do is do es sneakers right and
that
somehow made it the owner of es like i
know i know what the connection is but
it made it to one of the owners of es
sneakers i've been wearing es sneakers
exclusively it's the only skate shoe i
buy aside from being gifted some vans
and i love vans they're great but yes is
the ish i used to build outfits off of
es sneakers so what's you know dude the
the magnitude of my coolness in high
school with these es based outfits
is gonna be mind boggling to you when i
get some of these pictures for you
and see the plaid shirts that i matched
with them with the shoes to the beads in
my earrings you're gonna be like
oh so you've always been this cool so
there just wasn't it wasn't like a
gradual build up to this it was like you
came out the womb just killing it dog
and for some of you it's gonna be
surprising because i like i know i
preached like hardware like i wasn't
born buff i was bored of cool
okay
fantastic show last night at the
at the improv
where you know what the real thing i
want to talk about because sure okay
sure chris deleo brendan shop jeff dye
craig conant jim gaffigan all performed
and that was amazing but really we had a
special guest from toronto named grego
gallagher
aka kinobody somebody who i've talked
about here before
um he's got a great clothing line a
great supplement line and a great uh
system of programs that i encourage
people to check out because a lot of our
philosophies overlap as far as
minimalism and just you know reducing
this down doesn't need to be over
complicated
i like his diet model i think it's easy
for a lot of guys to follow and the
proof is in the pudding because he's
somebody who's created like literally
thousands of transformations
and many of them
i have good reason to believe her
natural like i don't assume everybody
doing his programs is you know but but i
believe he's natty and
he his program works for guys who are
natty so if you're starting from that
place that's a really good place to be
you know three days a week lifting
weights and a simple diet model uh to
get shredded like most guys could
benefit from this especially if you're
coming to me and going hey help me get
started that's one of the guys that'll
make check out this if you have a little
money right there's other free resources
on youtube but
if you have a hundred bucks to spend on
a program i would recommend that um he's
got a few different lifting programs and
like a you know an aggressive fat loss
product let's say you're at 20 body fat
and you want to get down to
you know 10 percent and gain muscle it's
probably going to be more efficient to
ramp up the dieting at first get down to
a weight where you can really see those
results and then add muscle so his
aggressive fat loss system is really
good but you know what
not here to pitch him anymore i wanted
to say it was cool meeting i love
meeting people who you talk to online
he's a really cool guy in person uh we
had a great time at the show and
hopefully we're gonna get a training
vlog in and a
haters will say interview
if time allows people are busy i don't
expect anybody's time i'm not entitled
to anybody's time
but
uh if we can make that happen that's
gonna be phenomenal and you guys are
gonna love it because again i think
he's a guy who kind of understands and
we talked about this a little bit last
night the
connection between
all the different things in what i would
refer to as the manosphere and what many
people would refer to as a manosphere
are
like male self improvement
and that connects to
getting women right that connects to
financial success that connects to
self-discipline
diet all these different things that
that also kind of just relate to general
life satisfaction and happiness but
aren't really mainstream ideas because
part of that is like becoming more
masculine
and i'm not equating getting buff with
being masculine but it is one of the
slices of that pie where you can feel
good about yourself and feel
confidence and also feel competence even
if it's as
at something as simple as lifting
weights it improves your self-esteem
just because you get good at something
and then you see results and you can
keep going with it for quite a while or
you can learn complex movements like
olympic lifting
you know or dead lifting even
getting better at stuff feels good
getting more muscle feels good uh you
know
creating a community around fitness
feels good all these things lead to
happiness confidence social skills
and potentially even a difference in the
way that people perceive you which then
is also going to be related to financial
success so i like looking at that idea
of
how to be a better person and
specifically a better more masculine man
if that's what you're into
and uh you know fitness covers
a lot of that you know the programs even
just how to dress because a lot of guys
are clueless with that so you know
having something like
you know clothing or oak and stone and a
lot of it you know there's some overlap
there i like both the brands and i'm
rocking the oakenstone right now because
it's designed for guys like all right
you get big now the problem is your
stuff doesn't fit well
now there's brands that market to you
specifically to make you look your best
all right and i'll just say i'm gonna
wrap it up
with a sup full finale here
the shows in philly were really cool and
it was really cool meeting people in
philly and i guess maybe as i do this
podcast more people have more of a
context to understand me
and talk to me about things that
uh i'm really into and that are a part
of my life so i just found myself having
deeper conversations and i want to
attribute it to philly and say like the
people are more interesting and engaging
in philly maybe that's true or maybe
it's just a byproduct of the fact that
as i put more of my life out there
people have more to then engage with me
on all right
look i'm going to touch on this real
quick what's how much time has passed
like three hours i'm not telling no i'm
just kidding uh 26 minutes 26 minutes
okay not too bad
because i wanted to
touch on something that people have
actually reached out to me about i'm
gonna call this section hella set
tragedies
i wanted to discuss recent events with
caleb von mooger and
again i'm always going to try to avoid
discussing drama for the sake of it i
know the amber heard trial is drama and
celebrity drama
specifically however i think there are
these unique angles that i find my way
into it and whether you find that
disingenuous or not i have no way of
knowing unless you tell me in the
comment section right now and debate it
out and make sure you leave hundreds of
comments and also call me a
pseudo-intellectual but then not be able
to back it up
so
i don't
want to bring drama like breaking news
drama or talk about it just like this
thing happened
i'm going to try to ask why
and
with caleb von moger we have
von
von mueller von mager i really don't
know how to say his last name and it's
one of those names that i'm just gonna
screw up over and over again please
forgive me
now
for those of you you who don't know this
this guy
you know the breaking news is he's now
able to walk and was released from the
hospital after jumping out of
a two-story building
or his house really he jumped through
the window and there was some i'm still
not quite sure exactly what happened
there was some rumors that there was
like drug dealers involved because
apparently he was getting into meth and
coke and been found with some stuff and
just acting erratically on social media
in general so we don't know if it was
like a suicide attempt or somebody was
maybe in the house like chasing after
him and threatening violence but he
jumped out
hurt his spine to the degree that he
couldn't walk and i think was put into a
uh you know medical coma for a certain
period of time to allow me to recover
and possibly detox from drugs now
rewind
where did this guy start while he was
one of the brightest stars in all
fitness
that's i guess where the tragedy comes
from and is set up by because
we hear about deaths a lot but a lot of
this stuff in bodybuilding is like
sudden deaths after the guy was kind of
leading a normal life or like
looked really good and there wasn't like
and it's shocking because it's like he
was doing his thing bodybuilding which
of course bodybuilding
at the elite level is very dangerous
when you're enhanced because of the
amounts of steroids you're taking just
the general stresses of that lifestyle
being super low body fat and
you know eating so much and putting this
stress on your body just from the
additional weight alone
so
uh he's a guy who started out he was a
competitive bodybuilder but of course
the lucrative nature of social media and
acting really you know it's like unless
you're winning shows at the highest
level and even then it's not that much
money so
this guy
was you know
a semi pioneer in in the social media
body building but you know he's got a
fantastic physique he's tall um just to
say you know because a lot of
competitive bodybuilders are shorter so
he's got kind of that arnold thing where
it's like oh here's this body but he's
also six three or you know whatever it's
just sort of unusual but his physique's
amazing he's got some tattoos which is
also kind of unconventional for a
bodybuilder and he's this like super
handsome australian guy who i don't find
him particularly charismatic outside of
like his looks and physique but you know
you don't really need that you can you
can rock it to stardom
even without being able to be the most
charismatic speaker per se however i
will say this he played arnold
schwarzenegger in the movie bigger he
wasn't
like the main character because it's
about the joe wieder
story and i
will be totally honest and say i haven't
seen the movie outside of clips from it
where he's acting but i was very
impressed with his acting like given
the fact that also yes i had super low
expectations for him but
even then i thought he did the accent
they put maybe a little bit of
prosthetics on him to look like arnold i
was like i buy this guy's arnold because
that could have been disastrous casey
you can confirm this
take a bodybuilder off the street and be
like hey play arnold schwarzenegger
999 times out of a thousand or more 999
you know
a million out of a million times outside
of caleb motor it's not gonna work uh
you know so i was very impressed by him
and you you go okay this yeah this guy
could act right
that's sort of rare like arnold is um
so
he had so many things going for him
what's the turning point here what is
the
uh you know part of his life or what is
the
incident
that led to this downfall because he
didn't go from that to just jumping out
of a window on math right
there was a few incidents that preceded
that and then it started to get dark and
that were those things were injuries
from some stupid preventable reckless
stuff right it's not like just training
it's like
for example he tours quad doing like a
rock climbing thing right so it's like
you know for me like
i look at rock climbing and it's like if
you use your body and it like if i was
in his position where this is my 100
money maker and i'm at this elite level
like i'd be careful right so he's sort
of a reckless guy to begin with but he
tours quad i think rock climbing
so you're just out like you know it's
like weeks months whatever
i think it was pretty bad like it tore
off the tendon maybe both of them i
remember i think i remember seeing him
like with like both legs in a cast so
you know it was a severe enough injury
that he had to take months of training
he also tore his bicep
doing
a curl with somebody else it was like
they're trying to curl like like two
guys standing next to each other like
trying to curl 405 i believe you know so
it's like okay if one if you could do
like a cheat curl with 225 which isn't
super it's very hard but if you're like
a super big jack guy it's like you could
do a cheat curl with that
why you would do that
with a partner at 405 pounds
is beyond me because the risk of you
tearing a tendon here this is such a
weak vulnerable part of your arm you
know and not that they if they perfectly
timed it they couldn't do it but like
if if you're not perfectly in sync then
one person is gonna like suddenly be
bearing like almost 400 pounds on your
bicep ten you know it's to recipe for
injury so stupid and preventable but all
these things kind of took him out an
injury if these things happen back to
back all of a sudden six months a year
you can't train properly
guess what if your identity and
your source of income and your source of
happiness is just your body
then
things might get a little depressing
things uh might take a turn
for the sad for the angry for the bitter
for
the looking for other things to replace
that such as drugs especially when
you're immobile you know with leg
injuries and you can't
turn to even running to do anything or
any alternate form of exercising because
it you know it doesn't matter if it's
lifting like just to get the feel good
out of exercise there's many things you
can do but if you can't do anything it
sort of makes sense right
there was some reports like that he was
doing drugs he starts to look different
your face gets thinner and more gaunt
there was a weird incident a few weeks
ago maybe months at this point where he
hit a kangaroo and beheaded it
not on purpose
the hitting not the beheading but you
know look kangaroos sure they're more
like deer in australia in america we
still have this like you hit a kangaroo
and it was dead and your decision was to
chop it into pieces with a chainsaw like
that sounds insane and unhinged and
uh you know
kind of when somebody then tells you
this guy's on meth you're like it checks
out
he put it on social media also which was
like you know again this is sort of like
the most immediate thing preceding him
jumping out the window
and uh to me it's indicative of
like
losing
touch with reality in a sense where you
think this is going to be funny or you
can't imagine how it would transl
to me but even a deer in america like i
don't know what like
were you aware of this casey not at all
okay
yeah i have no idea like what the reach
of is like caleb von mogger does
something crazy
in the fitness world the people i'm
following on youtube it's like whoa this
is nuts it probably won't reach anybody
else because
i mean is this too dark and too the
guy's not that famous enough right but
yeah he had a kangaroo
and put it all over social media that
like it was an accident sherpa that he
put in his truck and then he beheaded it
and he's like walking around with the
head and it's just like oh god like you
know and i get it i'm a hypocrite i eat
meat but
you most people
would look at that and go that just
doesn't first of all need to happen
uh because i think i would be very sad
if i hit a kangaroo or a deer you know
like and i have friends who've hit a
deer before and they're like it messed
up my whole month because i felt bad
about like smashing it's a traumatic
sudden thing it's like deer hunting or
like eating a steak it's like like
you're just like that ah like i just
murdered something
you know there's there's just much more
to process and much more like heightened
emotion to it so to turn right around
and like laugh it's like oh there's some
sort of deficit going on there and i do
think drugs turn you into
you know
in general especially
uppers like coke and meth
they're going to reduce your empathy and
your thoughtfulness and your ability to
access emotions like sadness
and we see that and
you know that's just to put a little pin
like here's where we were and then we
picked up with him
you know jumping out of a window and uh
you know having a severe back injury i
hope he gets better the point of me
bringing all this stuff in is
i personally really enjoy the fact that
i'm not connected
with my identity to my body
as much as i may have been in the past
there was a time when that was so so so
important to me and i wanted to get big
and i got up to you know bigger than i
am now at the age of
18 19
uh and
you know
after college i kind of looked at myself
and said i don't what's the purpose of
this what's the purpose of being 250 and
also i wanted to run away from that and
be like i just want to be perceived as
normal i don't want people to look at me
you know especially where i went to
college
that wasn't necessarily cool it's not
like the football team was like super
cool at pomona college um you know there
was
you're gonna get stereotyped anywhere
you go but
you know there wasn't like a culture of
groupies or something or it's like we're
playing at alabama and like oh it's a
cool football player it's like look at
this meathead he doesn't belong here
right so that's ingrained in your head
and you run away from that and for many
years as i probably have explained in
the last podcast you know it got down to
like 200 pounds and just
you know
i've spent time between not too extremes
per se but like
it allows you to form
identities outside of just being buff
and and i'm grateful for that and i
don't think anybody should be attached
to your body and say it can also work in
reverse where people are fat and they're
sort of like like i've known comedians
for example who are really fat and
they're worried about losing weight
because they think it'll make them not
funny
you know and there's not like it's not
crazy to think that because yeah like
being like being maybe we're more likely
to laugh at fat people being goofy and
kind of
like
we accept
like
the pre like without them having to
first self-deprecate you know or like
bring us down or make us comfortable
with laughing like we're comfortable
around this person being funny
easier and uh but i still think it's an
irrational fear it's like no you should
get healthy and do what you want to do
but even you know on both sides people
get attached to having a really nice
body and then get super depressed if
anything happens and they can't quite
hold on to this because they don't have
any other mechanism besides the mirror
to tell them they are who they are and
so experiencing and building an identity
around other things rather than just
aesthetics and just weightlifting and
just your body those are important you
know and having the right community and
other things other hobbies that make you
happy because i just see that as an
exist caleb mogar situated as an extreme
result of stuff like that where it's
like you're focused completely on one
thing you know almost like an olympian
or so it's like what if your whole life
was like you know
being a track star and your legs got
amputated you know at the age of like 23
when you were like about to go to the
olympics and you were you know the the
pick to win the gold medal
be pretty hard right like if you had
never developed any other thing
that's going to be really depressing and
perhaps you know you could see that
person going down some dark avenues so
i guess the message here is be
well-rounded
but i do hope caleb gets better makes it
for recovery and and uh
you know leaves all that behind him we
got like so many
this is why we can't have nice gyms
can we click on some of them let's just
do let's just you know bring it back to
a happy route this one's just like this
is like a super cut of everything that i
you know
this is like this is the this is why we
can't have nice gyms in one video
actually a guy like super arch like she
rips the barbell off a guy uh slipping
doing box jumps a guy do thinking he's
doing shrugs but he's just doing like
neck glitches a girl do you know
there's too much to keep up with a guy
doing lat raise like just air humps uh
lat pull air humps there's so much going
if you're listening to this podcast go
to
johncari.fit that's what the guy is
johncari.fit
and it's like him walking into the gym
and just seeing like
30 things that people do that we've all
seen in the gym like we've all seen
people doing these crazy half reps and
like on the cable flies like letting
them pull them back and forth like it's
a roller coaster ride and all that crap
um
good job my man putting that together
what's the next what do we got here okay
this is another night we
we can't have nice gyms because this
one's trying to do a hex bar deadlift
the wrong way like instead of like
like gripping like the handles that come
up and out she grips the other so it's
like rotate it you know would that be 90
degrees and so she picks it up
immediately it tilts because it's not
meant to bounce that way as it tips
forward the weight falls off
that part flies his hits her right in
the uh well it doesn't end in the face
it just like makes her fall backwards
because the weight counter balances the
to the back
those handles are saying please grab me
here yeah it's like
why would they be there otherwise like
to hit you in the face easier when you
drop it
this is not like i'm going to start
mixing in memes this one is just when
you start bench press and you feel your
left shoulder
acting up
and it's it's a breaking bad meme with
walter white like like reading a text
message and slamming the table in anger
because that's how it feels i think it's
just a relatable meme
what else we got oh my god
you know normally you see that kind of
arch
on a guy this guy has the most insane
arch i've ever seen he gives one of his
one-inch bench presses we'll we'll keep
playing this
the clips like these
because yes of course it's absurd and of
course the rules to change for bench
press and of course i'm an advocate for
rule changes and power lifting
competitions and that's something i just
super really care about
that guy's like a contortionist almost i
mean that's crazy to get in that
position
oh yeah it's insane
but that rep counts it technically does
and again the antidote to that would be
to limit per weight class how far you
can go out right
i thought this was a funny little gym
sketch good simple premise he says me at
my own wedding and he's just chilling
dude wife beat her sweatpants on doesn't
give a f
then it goes me and my homies pr attempt
and he's walking through the gym in a
suit and sunglasses i'm like yes that
guy is his priority straight
what else we got okay this was insane
this guy's doing like a like behind the
neck overhead press and freeze frame on
his arms bending away that they simply
shouldn't bend looks like you snapped
some tendons there in your elbow i'm
sorry to hear that but why wouldn't you
just let go of the bar
why wouldn't you when you feel it go
down like two inches past your traps
like you let it go what do you think
you're gonna like save it you know it's
like oh whoops i caught it
that's 50 yeah that's 25 kilo plates
that's a hundred and twenty you know two
that's like 265 pounds
and he's trying to like catch it behind
his back like it's a ten pound barbell
okay
this is just this is why we can have
nice females in lifting she does a from
the knees snatch in a dress in high
heels i love seeing the stuff it's also
raining outside it's raining yeah she's
got a towel down it's just badass
overall yeah good for her i love seeing
women like there's like a gender reveal
where like they did like a snatch and
like i don't know something like like
the
when she slammed it the balloons popped
or something like that i thought that
was cool it's just cool to see women
power like doing olympic lifting and
powerlifting anything
somebody wants do we does it wait is it
playing that hold on
yep this is like
another one where it's like let go of
the weight if you're push pressing and
it gets past one inch
beyond where you can feel that center of
gravity start to shift she just lets it
make her do a [ __ ] squat apparently
like you know was what it seems like
which is where you put all your weight
uh you know on your
toes as you bend your torso backwards in
a straight line from your knee to your
shoulders
and uh she's she's holding on to that
because look at that position it's like
what you're still holding on to this
push press
as it looks like you're just laying on a
flat bench almost
let it go
let it go
let it go
and then finally this is why we can't
have nice airports you know what i'm
about to play
so there's more to this video i didn't
realize but this is the famous airport
incident uh
you know do i know the dude's name no
but we talked about it on the fight of
the kid yesterday and i just wanted to
say
you can't initiate physical violence
with another man and not expect severe
consequences i would say if you're doing
this and of course the guy's like it's
to me it's not about like he was on the
job he was wrong of course you know he
was and in further video shows that
the airport employee even though the
clip is longer
looks like the airport and play like at
least took the first swing i don't know
if he connected but there was much more
to this
the guy kept coming at him and i just
think like you can't have sympathy for
somebody even though he did you know he
got knocked over it's humiliating for
him he's bleeding all that don't
initiate physical violence with another
man unless you're essentially
ready to murder him you know and deal
with those consequences because if
you're dealing with another guy who's
game to fight like that's where it's
gonna go you know like especially with a
pro athlete and i guess the guy was
you know the athlete was claiming he was
calling him uh you know names and
harassing the airport
and i'm not gonna die who knows because
people act crazy it's like you know you
suck you suck at football because you
lost a game on the team that i like or
you know
you played against the team that i like
and won
uh
don't do that never initiate violent be
prepared for it but don't ever initiate
that because
the consequences can be severe and swift
and you can get stabbed and i'm gonna
start doing segments on andrew tate
because he talks about that he's like
you know people training like
krav mcgraw and stuff like that he's
like cool cool cool but if somebody
wants to stab you with a knife they're
going to do it you know like if enough
guys surround you and want to do that
they're going to do it you're going to
die really quickly so what you need to
do is learn how to run
you know like boxing is cool too if
you're in a fight but when somebody
wants to perpetrate violence against you
there's very little you can do but run
so you have to essentially be you know
aware of your surroundings take the
headphones out of your ears okay
we got some mark harley memes of the
week you know daniel rabone back at it
with some classic bangers he sends me
these
i appreciate
this is that classic like the first ones
that you know the guy looking back at
the girl that's crossing and the his
girlfriend is like looking at him like
what are you serious
and this is me with lionface or it's
supposed to be me with
beauty and the beast is that what it is
oh yeah like it looks like me i'll be
honest
and then the guy looking is the t fat k
subreddit
and then t faking because the t5k
subreddit is ignoring t5k uh for me
which is true
um
which is definitely true
i'm just gonna real quick i'm gonna read
this for context but
um
you know
so the last episode i said tune in at 6
00 pm pst today if for nothing else then
the comment section will which will
inevitably be filled with as much mental
gymnastics and venomous defensiveness as
you'd expect from the single most
sensitive anonymous hate group on reddit
spoiler alert none of them will
gain an ounce of self-awareness
listening to my psychoanalysis haters
will say it's because i'm not good at
psychoanalysis and not because i'm
talking to an emotionally stunted man
babies who can't find employment outside
of the friars at p.f chang's link will
appear in biowuen's story as soon as it
drops
so
i in that episode
i challenge people to find my mental
illness i
you know
called out the subreddit for doing the
things that they've been doing really
explicitly and said
you know
guys have asked my mom made fun of my
dead father then accused me of
doing that all to myself yadda yadda
and you can you can do whatever you want
actually don't erase comments you know
from uh any of these episodes so you can
do what you want
i got called pseudo-intellectual like 30
times and as many of the responses that
i could get to as many of these comments
that i could respond to i'd say yeah
tell me one thing
that indicates i'm a pseudo-intellectual
tell me one thing you disagree with or
want to challenge me on or say my
interpretation is indicative of
pseudo-intellectualism
i did not get a single response
i challenged people to find my mental
illness and as i said one person listed
symptoms of narcissism so i listed
symptoms of pedophilia
um
and then the real response to that was
to start making mo me
the real response to that
that has popped up that i've gotten on
my page probably like 200 300 times and
apparently there's a lot of posts on it
on reddit
is that i have small feet oh
i think it's safe to say it's a
conversational tko
if i say
hit me with your best shot
and you call me a pseudo-intellectual
and can't back it up and can't define
the mental illness that i suffer from
and you accuse me of having small feet
and that's the best you got
oh
case closed
you're not that good at what you do
and this is over
so
back to the memes
separated hate group classic meme i
don't even know whose actresses are but
it's like the cat with the salad on the
other side
i love this format though i don't know
if he knows it and i love this format
and all things but
i'm so bad like you
and the cat's like
right triangle face
we got hella fat heart look this is me
and all like
oh this is funny to you okay see this is
funny to you yeah this is funny to you
yeah i like it
okay i like it because you're fat
i like izzy
in real life you're not fat but then if
you get fat that's what you look like
and then what do we have next oh
it's me and brendan fake brothers
the movie coming to a theater near you
and this isn't a mark harley meme i just
thought this was like so innocent and
funny like it's like so simple this next
one
so it's a cartoon
told in three boxes here three frames
it's a blue crayon
getting a call say hey red what's
shaking
red on the line says hey blue can you
swing by the hospital
blue's like sure why
then it cuts to red in the hospital with
his wife the yellow crayon
and their babies green dun dun dun
and he says just want to talk
like you got cucked by a blue crown bro
and the nurses are orange okay liver
king neither we're going to finish off
with the liver king
those are their other two children oh
because red and yellow make orange
so we know who's a pseudo-intellectual
here
mark mark
mark pretended to know how colors mix i
then immediately revealed that he's no
color expert after all
like yeah those nurses are really short
too i wonder why
why
the other crayons seem so big in
comparison to these orange small nurses
that's okay you know why cause casey was
one of these people claiming i'm a
pseudo-intellectual he gets to go on my
comments be like hey mark you don't know
that that red plus yellow equals orange
so that's you know i'd have to be like
all right
no conversational tko there except like
from you to me okay let's play this
little
clip
i just thought that the
this is uh from the not you know not fit
memes
bloody maple syrup it's okay
the real reason i'm playing this if they
cheers their bones and have bone marrow
he goes everything about this man is
repulsive
[Laughter]
funny to me i don't know and here we
have a screenshot i think this might be
real
the guy goes does liver
does king this liver king liver queen
and like he leaves off the f for queef
and then liver king responds
does cole ames know what it's like to be
worthy to behold such a queen
a queen's queef would blow you into
oblivion
i hope that's him i really hope like it
kind of seems like on character for him
because he kind of gets raunchy and
swears and stuff like that
um and i just i continue to find him as
a source of entertainment i'm not hating
on you liver king
but you know if you ever think we're
going to drop this segment your odd
goddamn mind
um
protein pony shirts and merchandise
coming soon